here to discuss the politics of the week
is been Goldberger executive editor at
Time magazine Ben good morning morning
I'm sure we'll get to that meeting in a
moment but I want to go back to Muller
and obviously this news buy the House
Judiciary Committee and the lawsuit give
us some sense with Muller testifying
with this lawsuit and trying to get that
redacted information where do we stand
with all of this well that's a really
good question
the answer is nobody fully knows but the
Democrats are unwilling to give up on
the prospect of at least beginning
impeachment proceedings if not the
actual impeachment process itself so the
lawsuit that's filed by the Judiciary
Committee is an attempt to preserve the
potential for impeachment without
forcing a full house vote which as of
now is unlikely to pass and is exactly
what Leader Nancy Pelosi is adamant
about having happened and we don't seem
to have any more interest from the
American people right now in seeing this
go forward we haven't had as you and I
were talking about the social media
moment of this yet well that's exactly
and that's what accounts for the split
among the Democrats so after Muller's
testimony as of today there's somewhere
around 100 101 Democrats who favor
pushing for impeachment but that's not a
majority of their caucus it's certainly
not going to pass a
republican-controlled Senate and so
without widespread support of the
American public Pelosi and many of her
colleagues don't see the wisdom and
pushing for it the second round of
democratic debates coming up here in
just a few days it'll be interesting to
see how much Muller consumes that
conversation and that debate when it
happened absolutely but that's a
fundamental tension among many of the
candidates running I think there's about
12 of them who favor impeachment
proceedings but if there's any lesson to
be learned from not just Clinton's
campaign against Trump but pretty much
every single presidential election you
win by telling the voters what your for
not what you're against and so no matter
how unpopular Trump is and he is
historically unpopular for a modern
president at this point in their term no
Democrat is going to beat him simply by
railing against him clearly the
president took a victory lap after the
Moller hearings but how does this play
into his overall strategy I mean he has
the squad issue with telling them to go
back to where you came from it's just it
seems to be just you know
keeps moving forward well he he has
built a campaign predicated on division
that was that was a key theme of his
election in 2016 and it's one he's going
back to now even though as many of his
supporters point out he actually has
tangible accomplishments to run on and
yet he seems much more insisting on
stoking certain nativist sentiment
racial animus us first then division
indeed but then again he's sort of a
victim of his own expectations the
economy is doing very very well there's
a lot of job growth and some of that is
the result of the tax cuts and a lot of
the very intense stimulus from the
trouble administration but he's also
promised that there would be annual 3%
growth he has not achieved that okay Ben
Goldberger thank you very much thank you